what do we get the same broken corrupt
institution the American people despise
over and over and over again until
someone says yo I don't care to be part
of a broken institution I will stand
against it to try and fix it like like
Matt is doing actually until we get more
people joining in it's just the American
people are going to keep spitting on and
laughing at and mocking Congress yeah I
think I mean the term liit thing would
solve a lot of the problems I think that
that would solve a even a lot of the
financial problems uh because a freshman
member comes in they typically don't get
the best committee assignments and but a
lot of the lobbyists and the big the big
special interest groups they see who has
the potential to climb the ranks and
eventually get the chairmanship or a
ranking member uh position on these
committees and once you that's when you
have the real power that's when you
decide where the money's going that's
when you decide who's getting the
contracts and so um you know if you're
only in there for 12 years like you know
you you don't really have the time to
play that game